FEMALE SPEAKER: My
name is [INAUDIBLE]
and I work in our
People Operations team.
And I'm really excited
to introduce Doctor John
Ioannidis.
John is a professor of medicine,
health research and policy,
and statistics at Stanford.
So not just one,
but all of those.
He's also the co-director of
the very recently launched
Meta-Research Innovation
Center at Stanford,
also known as METRICS, which
is a research-to-action center
whose purpose is to
advance excellence
in scientific research.
Previously, John was chairman
at the Department of Hygiene
and Epidemiology
at the University
of Ioannida School of
Medicine in Greece,
as well as an adjunct
professor at Tufts University
School of Medicine.
John is best known for his
research and published papers
on scientific studies,
particularly the 2005 paper
"Why Most Published Research
Findings Are False"--
I can't understand why that
one was controversial--
which has been the most
downloaded technical paper from
the leading open access medical
journal "The Public Library
of Science."
John's current work is focused
on improving research design
standards.
And today's talk is titled
"Reproducible Research-- False
or True?"
The talk is being
live-streamed and recorded,
so we ask that questions
are held until the end
and that you wait
for a microphone
so that everyone can
hear your questions.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. John Ioannidis.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. IOANNIDIS: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE].
I would like to share
some thoughts with you,
and I realize it's
a videotaped talk.
But this doesn't mean that
you should not interrupt.
Actually, please do interrupt.
Because otherwise it's going
to be very boring lecture,
I presume.
It's a great pleasure
to be here to share
these thoughts with you.
Science is a big enterprise.
We're talking about
15 million people
that have published papers
indexed in SCOPE in the last 15
years.
And this is about
25 million papers.
Now I'm sure that Google
Scholar has better coverage,
but I couldn't find the exact
numbers for that time period.
Any guess?
Maybe it's 30 million.
That have at least one item
listed under Google Scholar.
So how many
discoveries do we have
in science in these
last 15 years?
Major discoveries?
Maybe a few thousand?
I see two.
OK.
I'm an optimist.
I think we have several
thousand, but really not
15 million discoveries.
So far less than one
per person, on average.
Probably one in 1,000, or one in
10,000, maybe one in a million,
depending on how
you look at that.
Self-correction should work.
So even though we don't make
big discoveries all the time,
we find small pieces that
may be correct or wrong.
And we can correct
them if they're wrong.
The ability of
self-correction is
considered one of the
main features of science.
In a cumulative
meta-analysis framework,
if sufficient time elapses,
then we will get to the truth.
Eventually.
But the question is how
quickly do we get there?
Of course we corrected
that the Earth is not
the center of the world,
and the Sun is not
going around the Earth, but
it took us about 2,000 years
to do that.
So an issue of efficiency arises
on how we could do that faster.
Self-correction is often not
happening promptly enough.
It may be impeded by
destruction of evidence,
production of wrong evidence,
or distortion of evidence.
Here's the possibilities
of what could happen
when we have a new
discovery being proposed
and efforts to replicate it.
We have the optimal path,
which is that the discovery is
correct and the
replication is correct.
The self-correcting,
the discovery was wrong,
but the replication was correct.
The false nonreplication,
the discovery was correct
but the replication was wrong.
The perpetuated fallacy,
discovery was wrong,
the replication was also wrong.
And challenge fallacy,
discovery was wrong
and replication was not
done, because people
didn't think that
they should do it.
And unconfirmed genuine
discovery, the discovery
was correct and the replication,
again, was not done.
Now different fields
have different profiles
of these six options in terms of
their frequency and prevalence.
And I'm going to
show you some data
from psychological science.
This includes a
lot of disciplines.
And it's summing some
empirical studies
that were published last year.
Well, late 2012, a
year and a half ago.
In "Perspectives on
Psychological Science,"
I was asked to summarize
all these empirical studies
on one paper in that same issue.
And here's how it looks like.
The optimal represents less
than 1% of that literature.
The self-correcting,
again, less than 1%.
False nonreplication,
far less than 1%.
Perpetuated fallacy, 2%.
Unconfirmed genuine
discovery, 43%.
And unchallenged fallacy, 53%.
There's a lot of uncertainty
in these numbers.
They could be better than that,
they could be worse than that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do we
know it was a fallacy
if it was unchallenged?
DR. IOANNIDIS: OK.
Good question.
Based on what we
see whenever we do
take an extra step to do that.
The only way to
discriminate rigorously
between these
categories is when we
do have an effort
at replication.
So psychological
sciences in general
have a culture that replication
is not really very advantageous
for the promotion
of someone's career.
But many of the
scientific fields
have developed some
replication culture,
and we have more evidence
on how frequently results
do get replicated.
When we have empirical evidence
in fields where replication
practices are common, then most
the time most of the initially
claimed statistically
significant effects
are either false positives
or substantially exaggerated.
And here's a few examples.
This is genetic epidemiology,
where for many years
we were running
tens of thousands
of studies in the very same way
that we continue to do research
in most scientific fields.
We had a hypothesis.
In that case, we thought
that one gene may
be related to some disease,
and we were testing for that.
And we were coming
up with papers.
I have published lots of such
papers saying that that gene is
associated with the risk of
major depressive disorder,
smoking, acute coronary
syndrome, osteoporosis,
coronary artery
disease, da-da-da-da-da.
And then we have a revolution.
People realize that,
well, we're not really
making much progress.
How about joining forces?
Instead of each one of us
publishing a small study,
we have lots of studies
coalescing into consortia.
And we can measure the whole
genome instead of one snippet
at a time.
By doing that, we
have the ability
to try to see what happened
to all of that literature
where we thought that
we had identified
57 loci for major depression,
359 loci for smoking,
and so forth.
And this is the
replicated gene loci
in that new agnostic
testing arena.
The replication rate is 1.1%.
So 98.9% of the
original discoveries
were not reproduced.
And this is pretty much the mode
that most scientific fields,
especially in
biomedicine, at least,
are still working at one
hypothesis at a time,
or a few hypotheses at
a time, or publishing
one or a few
hypotheses at a time.
This is one other field.
This is nutritional
epidemiology.
And this is an apples and
oranges meta-analysis.
Actually it's not an apples
and oranges meta-analysis.
It's a wine and tomatoes and tea
and sugar and salt and potato
and pork and onion and many
other things meta-analysis.
So what we tried to
do, we took a cookbook,
literally, "The
Boston Cookbook,"
and randomly selected
50 ingredients.
And we asked the
question for how many
of these 50 ingredients
that you can eat,
that-- We just had
lunch, for example.
Several of them were
probably in what I ate.
How many of them have
scientific studies claiming
an increased or decreased
risk for cancer?
What would be your guess?
AUDIENCE: 48.
DR. IOANNIDIS: 48.
OK.
Very close.
We found 40.
Actually, the other
10 do have studies,
but we just searched
in a way that we
tried to find the
exact ingredient.
So for example, vanilla
was not among the 40.
It was among the 10 that
we didn't find a study.
But if you search for vanillin,
which is within vanilla,
you would have found studies
trying to associate vanillin
with increased or
decreased cancer risk.
And this is the effect sizes.
This is the relative
risks for different types
of food ingredients.
And this is for different
types of cancer.
And these are relative risks of
decrease, if it's less than 1,
or increase per roughly
one serving per day.
So if you take
literally a 0.5, it
means that with one
more serving per day,
you can halve the
burden of cancer.
One more serving of
tea, for example.
According to that study,
you cut cancer risk by 60%.
One more serving per
day here, so potatoes,
one more serving per day, you
double the risk of cancer.
Around the world, one more
serving of potatoes per day
will double the cancer
risk around the world.
How many of these estimates do
you think are close to reality?
Let's say reality
plus, minus 5%.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So very, very few.
And most likely
it's the ones that
are very close to
that line of 1.
I'm a professor of medicine
and disease prevention,
so I do believe that
several of these foods
do affect cancer risk.
And I think that
it also makes sense
to try to promote, for
example, fruits and vegetables
or to decrease, for
example, I think
pork has mostly
bad studies there.
And red meat probably has
increased cancer risk.
But the best studies, the
ones that are least biased,
for fruit and
vegetables, suggest
that with one
serving per day, we
can have a relative
risk of 0.998.
So it would be almost
indistinguishable
to that vertical line of 1.
But it is a benefit.
And if you translate it
to a global population,
it would mean tens of
thousands of people
would be spared from
cancer if we do that.
But it's not a 0.5.
It's not a 2.
It's not 0.7 or a 1.3.
Here's one other field,
pharmacoepidemiology.
Here we had the benefit
of having access
to the data on prescriptions
for many years,
and on cancers over many
years, of an entire country.
Sweden.
Sweden has amazing registries.
And our colleagues
Kristina and Jan Sundquist
at the University of Lund do
have access to these databases.
So what we did here, we
just did an analysis.
We are trying to associate all
medications against all cancer.
There's about 2,000 different
types of medications.
We grouped them into
550-something clusters,
because there's several
beta-blockers, for example.
And here are the
results as p values,
this is minus log 10 p value,
for different categories
of medication.
So these are classes.
And three out of four medication
classes may affect cancer risk.
I did this analysis.
I think it's correct.
Well, who knows.
But do you believe
that this is sensible?
That three out of four
medication classes
would increase or
decrease cancer risk?
Some of these p
values-- This is 100.
It means a p value of
10 to the minus 100.
Zero point da-da-da.
Yes.
It's an amazing number.
I mean, in terms of
statistical significance,
you cannot get any
better than that.
But in fact, it's very likely
that very, very few of these
medications affect cancer risk.
What is happening here
is we're facing big data
with lots of confounding.
Even if you run the
very best analysis,
you will see lots
of that confounding
coming to the surface and giving
you signals right and left.
Each of them could be
a publishable paper.
I think we can
publish a few hundred
papers out of that
project alone.
Or probably none.
Now more replication.
I think if we have replication
in an additional data set,
some of these problems
will disappear.
You will not see
it again and again
unless you have the same biases
appearing again and again.
Who's going to do that?
Well, the industry,
recently, has
been challenged asking
for more replication.
I have been surprised,
because many years ago I
was struggling to convince
that we need to replicate some
of the classics of, for
example, drug intervention.
And the industry was
very defensive on that.
But now, when it comes
to pre-clinical research,
colleagues from
several companies
have tried to reproduce
academic research done
in the very best centers by
the very best scientists.
And trying to see, if I have
pre-clinical drug targets that
have been published
in the top journals,
can I reproduce these results?
Because I want to
use these results
to be able to
develop my new drug
to become the new blockbuster.
So this is how it looks like.
Very, very bad replication
rates by several teams
at Amway and Bayer
and other companies.
70 to 89% nonreplication.
For the Amgen project, only
six of the 53 landmark studies
could be reproduced.
And that was even after asking
the original investigators
to specify exactly
what they were
doing to get these results.
So the conclusions in that
paper, for example in "Nature"
a couple years ago,
that the failure
to win the war on cancer has
been blamed on many factors,
but recently a new
culprit has emerged.
Too many basic scientific
discoveries are just wrong.
This means that
hedge funds often
don't trust science nowadays.
This is a statement
from a journal
that I don't read routinely.
It's in the interface
of business and science.
It says that at least
50% of published studies,
even those in top-tier
academic journals,
cannot be repeated with the same
conclusions by an industrial
lab.
And the potential for not being
able to reproduce academic data
is a disincentive to
early-stage investors.
At least one venture
capital, [INAUDIBLE]
and now there's
far more than that,
is hiring contract
research organizations
to independently validate
academic science prior
to putting up serious money.
Which means that this is bad
news for me as a Stanford
professor.
It means that my work,
I'm doing that maybe
for fun, to get promoted,
to get my next grant,
but if you really
want to trust my work,
find someone else to repeat it.
Otherwise you cannot
take it for granted.
I need to fight back to
regain my reputation.
I think it's extremely
important that I
don't leave that perception
to be floating around.
Some countries are probably
even worse in that regard.
And this is a piece of work
that I did with Dan Fanelli
and came out about six
months ago in "PNAS."
We used data from two extremes.
One is genomics, where
measurement is very accurate,
and the other is
psychology and psychiatry
and behavioral sciences,
where the measurement's
pretty subjective.
And we asked the
question is there
more bias in one field
versus the other?
And is there more bias
with extreme results
in studies coming from specific
countries versus others?
What we found, number
one, there is bias.
Probably.
Small studies tend to give
exaggerated results which
are not seen in larger studies.
In both fields.
But when it comes to
subjective outcomes
like behavioral sciences,
then the US studies
are far more likely to
find extreme results.
Why is that?
One might argue
that maybe there's
more pressure in the US.
Or at least this is reflecting
studies done, on average,
a few years ago to
several years ago.
Maybe for an academic
investigator,
there's more pressure to
deliver a significant finding,
an extreme finding, in
order to get it published
in a major journal and
continue to get funded.
I think this has become
probably a global perspective
at the moment, but maybe
when we analyzed these data,
it was far more prominent
in the United States.
Why research findings
may not be credible?
Is there something
wrong with science?
There's nothing
wrong with science.
I think science is the best
that we have, as human beings,
to understand the world,
to understand ourselves,
to understand what
is happening and what
might happen in the future.
But unavoidably, there is bias.
And also there's random error.
Which means lots of
comparisons being done.
And usually there's
plenty of both.
And the question is can we
dissect these two forces
and minimize them?
How many biases are out there?
I don't know.
I'm considered to be an expert
on bias, but I had no clue.
So I was trying to
create a list of bias,
and when I met [INAUDIBLE]
a number of years ago,
he said, "Why don't we have the
computer read the entire PubMed
overnight and tell us how
many biases we can identify."
So this is a galaxy of biases.
It's 235 biases mapped across
17 million PubMed papers.
I have to say I have never
heard about a third of them.
And I'm considered
to be an expert.
How many of these biases
do I think ahead of time
when I design a new study?
Probably very few.
But this doesn't mean
that they do not exist.
So even methodologists
cannot really anticipate all
the biases that may occur.
This is a time array
for biases slide.
It shows how popular they are in
the literature, how many people
are talking about them.
So if you see white color,
it means that they are hot.
People are discussing them.
Here's an error, 1882.
One of the many errors,
probably, I have made.
And if you see black, it means
that no one is interested.
There's no papers
discussing that bias.
However, even when people are
discussing about bias-- so
for example, "confounding"
is the most common bias term
in the literature, and
since the late 1970s
it has been discussed by
many, many papers-- what
do people say about confounding?
Every epidemiological
paper in the discussion
will say confounding
is a problem
with epidemiological studies.
However, our study does
not have that problem.
Because we did a very
good job in whatever way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you briefly
explain what confounding means?
DR. IOANNIDIS: So
confounding means
that you have some exposure
that is related both to the risk
factor that you're
interested to study
and with the outcome that
you're interested to study.
But the effect does not
go through the risk factor
that you want to study.
This is the official definition.
Practically, it means that
the two groups that you're
comparing to try to see
if the risk factor has
an impact on the
outcome are unbalanced
in an important way in
regard to that confounder.
The confounder is not the same
in those who have the risk
factor and those who do
not have the risk factor.
So it's the main reason
why in the analysis
of the medications,
for example, I
see that 3/4 of the
classes of medications
have an association
with cancer risk.
It's confounding.
Confounding by indication,
in that case, most likely.
And other types of confounding.
But most of the times
that we discuss bias,
we do that to try to say
that our study is protected.
Same thing for publication bias.
Publication bias is a very
popular term in meta-analysis.
Almost every meta-analysis,
if you read the discussion,
it says publication bias
is a threat to analysis,
however, our meta-analysis
is probably immune to that
or not affected,
because we did x or y,
or we think that it's
not a problem here.
In many cases, when we have
the benefit of multiple studies
that try to replicate
the original findings,
we see that correction
of the bias.
So these are
genetic associations
that were proposed many years
ago in leading journals.
And when they were proposed,
they were highly cited papers,
they were highly statistically
significant results.
But as we did more studies
on the very same association,
the cumulative odds ratio
gravitated towards the null.
And at the end of the
day, at the latest update,
there was no longer any signal
that it was even nominally
statistically significant.
However, to do that, you
need a replication culture.
You need a situation
where people
are willing to perform these
additional replications.
And as I said, this
is not very frequent.
Question.
AUDIENCE: The graphic
in the last slide,
is that possibly explaining
[INAUDIBLE] regression
to the mean about
that publication bias?
DR. IOANNIDIS: So the question
is whether this behavior would
be attributed also to a
regression to the mean.
It could be, to some extent.
And some of these
diminishing effects
could be regression to the
mean for some effects that
are genuine but inflated
when we first discover them.
And I think I'll show
some examples about that.
In most of these cases
that I show here,
I think the most likely scenario
is that they were just null.
And were chance findings
that we perform replication,
they go away.
But the possibility of
regression to the mean
is there for other situations.
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference between those two?
They seem like kind
of the same things.
Publish the most
interesting results,
they'll regress to the mean.
DR. IOANNIDIS: Yeah.
What is the difference between
the two is that in one case,
there's absolutely nothing.
And we have an
exaggerated result
that reflects a
completely null truth.
And the second
possibility is that we
have an exaggerated result that
reflects some truth, partially.
There is a signal,
there's a true signal,
but it's not as big
as we have found.
So qualitatively,
it is different.
In one case, there's nothing.
In the other case,
there is something.
In terms of the
magnitude of the fact,
if you look at the
exaggeration, it
could be equally big
in both circumstances.
This is another empirical
evaluation looking at the creme
de la creme of
clinical research.
What I've looked at
here is the studies
that were published
in any medical journal
and have been the most
cited in the literature.
So those that got more
than 1,000 citations.
And trying to see whether
additional studies were done
down the road to see if
they would replicate what
the original studies
had proposed.
Five out of six
nonrandomized studies
could not be replicated.
They were found to be either
completely wrong or grossly
exaggerated.
And about 25% of
randomized trials
were also found to be either
completely wrong or grossly
exaggerated.
And this is the
creme de la creme.
This is the most influential
clinical research,
and this is the type
of nonreplication rate
that we witness.
AUDIENCE: What does "randomized"
mean in that context?
DR. IOANNIDIS:
"Randomized" means
that this is clinical
research, so we
want to see whether a
drug or a lifestyle change
or whatever is effective
in reducing mortality
or cardiovascular deaths
or cancer or whatever.
So we randomly create
the two populations
that will get the intervention
or not get the intervention.
So it's the best way that
we can study interventions,
because it's as
unbiased as it could be.
The two groups are
generated by chance,
and therefore they should
be similar in terms
of whatever other
characteristics they have.
If they're not similar,
then we have the potential
for confounding that we
were mentioning earlier.
So much of the
time, what we get is
what I would call excess
significance bias.
People want to get
significant results.
And the ways to do
that are manifold.
But at the end of the
day, they boil down
to three different mechanisms.
Results that become
positive while they should
have been negative.
Results that are negative
that are being suppressed.
Never published, not visible.
And fake positive
results that are
being created out of vacuum.
There's no data,
there's no patients,
there's no information
in reality,
and someone creates
a fake paper.
I don't think that the
third mechanism is common.
Scientists are not saints, but
I think that on average, we're
a very honest bunch of people.
You may see cases
of fraud coming
to the forefront
of the news, but I
think this is a very
uncommon scenario.
I don't think that someone
would waste their whole life
to be trained as a scientist
to be a fraudulent manipulator.
But results that are
negative that are suppressed
are probably not uncommon.
And I think this first
mechanism-- results
that are really negative when
the original intention, what
was the original protocol,
the original hypothesis,
they do become
positive by changing
that analysis by adding an
extra layer of exploration
to the data set-- I think
this probably pretty common.
At the end of the day,
the common consequence
of all these practices
is an inflation
in the proportion of
observed positive results.
And that means
that one would have
too many studies with
significant results.
That would mean even
seemingly replicated results
in the same question.
Too many significant
results is not necessarily
a sign of replication.
It could mean something
is going wrong here.
And here's one indirect
insight into this.
This is another paper by
Dan Fanelli where there's
a sample of papers evaluated
across different scientific
fields.
And the conclusion
is that fields
that have more rigorous
research practices and more
rigorous criteria for claiming
discoveries, like physics
and space science,
for example, they
have the lowest proportion
of statistically significant
results in their literature.
Conversely, fields like
psychiatry, psychology,
clinical medicine, pharmacology,
toxicology, material science,
they have about 90%,
sometimes more than that.
There's some journals that only
publish significant papers.
You take a whole issue and it's
only significant papers there.
They have a 95% or
more, sometimes,
significant results
that they get published.
This is just too
good to be true.
And the question, then, is
what do we do with that?
What solutions might we have?
And I will discuss a few of
these potential solutions
in the last 10, 15 minutes.
One is to learn to live
with small and tiny effects.
I know that maybe
this is not very
attractive to say in Silicon
Valley, where everybody says
that we have the new major
discovery of the future,
of the 21st century, or the
third millennium, or whatever.
Yes, that would be great, but
most of the genuine effects
that we are going
to find and document
are going to be pretty small.
There's an empirical
evaluation of risk factors
and interventions
with tiny effects,
meaning odds ratios
less than 1.05.
I think many of those are real.
And actually, in many
sizes, these tiny effects
are likely to be the
majority of them.
In biological sciences, I
think, most of the effects
to be discovered are likely
to be very, very small.
Maybe even smaller than 1.05.
One of them alone is not
going to change the world.
But a thousand of them?
If we can combine information
from 1,000 tiny effects,
we would get more than
a major discovery.
So we may just need to
realign our expectations
about what we're chasing.
Second possibility is to
try to rigorously replicate
whatever large effects we find.
If you're talking
about single studies,
large effects are pretty common.
So this is an
empirical evaluation
where we looked at half
of the medical literature
for clinical trials.
We used data from 220,000
clinical trials' worth of data
that had been included in 85,000
meta-analyses in the Cochrane
Collaboration, Cochrane Library.
And this covers any type
of medical intervention.
How often do you think, across
this whole medicine evidence,
do we have interventions that
pertain to mortality risk,
they reduce mortality
risk by fivefold--
so if 10 people were to
die only two or fewer
are going to die-- significant
results at p value of 0.001
or less, and no clear
evidence for huge bias
that you can easily discern?
So this is the entire
medicine, more or less,
220,000 randomized trials.
Or, well, to be exact,
about half of it.
How many medical
interventions can do that?
Increased mortality fivefold
and have really strong support
from clinical trials?
Any guess?
Out of the 85,000 meta-analyses?
Close to zero.
We found one.
So not zero.
There is a few more.
And I said this is not
the entire medicine,
and there is some
interventions that have never
been tested in clinical trials.
So insulin for diabetes
was discovered before even
randomized trials
were discovered.
But really there's
very, very few
that achieve such huge benefits
and are well documented.
Extracorporeal oxygenation
for premature babies.
It does have such a huge effect.
So the question
that one has to ask
is how much vibration of
effects is there in the results
that I see?
By vibration of
effects, I mean how many
opportunities have there been
in the background of that result
to be obtained?
Has there been only one analysis
that would have been done,
or is it multiple analyses, and
maybe people have cherry-picked
what analyses they
wanted to present?
And this is a manifestation
of the vibration
of effects in grand scale.
That's a study that I did
with Chirag Patel and Melinda
Burford where we tried to
evaluate different risk
factors for mortality
in NHANES, which
is a large database from a
household survey in the US.
And we ask the question can
you get different results
if you analyze the
same data differently?
And for each one
of these data sets,
we have analyzed the same
association, the same risk
factor, in about a
million different ways.
And this is the
cloud of the results.
The p value and the hazard
ratio that you get for death.
There's lots of risk
factors, like vitamin E
here, alpha-tocopherol,
that you can get this shape,
which suggests that depending
on how you analyze the data,
you can get a result to suggest
that alpha-tocopherol increases
mortality, or you
can get a result that
shows that alpha-tocopherol
increases mortality.
So you can get decrease,
increase, no effect,
whatever you wish.
If you're a believer that
alpha-tocopherol should do x,
you can get that x.
I mean, just play with the data
and you'll get what you want.
Another possibility
is to promote
large-scale collaboration.
So I showed you
the example where
we thought that we had
found 359 gene loci that
regulate smoking behavior.
When we decided to join forces
and perform a very large study,
a consortium study, with very
rigorous statistical methods
and look across the whole
genome, we found only four.
And actually only none of
these four was one of the 359
that we thought would be there.
So we killed 359, we found four.
Since we published
that study, the number
is up to seven that have
been well documented.
Is that bad news?
I would say this is good news.
We have seven now that
we know are genuine.
They have very strong
statistical support,
very rigorous replication
across all these teams
that have joined forces.
Reporting of research could
also make a difference.
Many papers are very
difficult to understand
what is happening.
The methods are very
sketchy, the results
are fragmented, and forget
about the discussion.
So there's lots of
efforts, and all these
have been brought under
the umbrella of the EQUATOR
Network led by Doug Altman at
Oxford, trying to put together
all these efforts to standardize
reporting of research
results of different
types of designs.
Registration, I think, could
also make a difference.
You can think of studies' being
registered ahead of time rather
than just wait for studies
to appear out of the blue.
You know that a
study does exist.
And I think that
the major problem,
as I tried to describe
in that paper in "JAMA"
is not really papers
on studies that exist.
I worry mostly about
studies that don't exist.
And you may think
that I'm paranoid.
But let me try to explain why I
fear studies that don't exist.
I fear studies that
could potentially
exist if someone were to spend
the time to create that study.
So we have a data set.
There's millions of
studies that could
be created out of that data set.
So what I would like
to know is really
what data sets are
out there and what
could be done with
these data sets.
What is the potential?
It's like mapping
nuclear weapons.
None of them has have been sent.
The missiles are not
sent to target yet,
but it's good to know that
there's 10,000 missiles that
could be launched at some point.
And these are the different
levels of registration
that you can think of
for any scientific study.
Level zero would
be no registration.
It means that no
one has registered
that idea or that product or
that data set or whatever,
and here it comes.
I've never heard about
that that it was happening.
Fine.
Let's keep it.
But it means that we
need to replicate it.
Otherwise it's very, very
unlikely that it would be true.
Some of them would be true.
But not very high chance.
Registration of data
set is what I described.
We know what data sets
and opportunities exist.
Registration of protocol.
It means that we have started
formulating a hypothesis.
We do have a hypothesis.
Then people would
know about that.
Registration of
the analysis plan
is different than
registration of protocol,
because analysis plan is
an extra level of detail
on how exactly the data
are going to be analyzed.
And even seasoned
analysts acknowledge
that the analysis plan may
really change down the road.
Registration of the analysis
plan and the raw data,
which means that if
people have time to waste,
they can go back
to their own data
and try to repeat
that analysis and see
whether they get
the same results.
And finally open
live streaming, which
means that I do my
research, I open my computer
to public view, and you can
start sending me messages.
John, don't push that button,
don't run that chi-square test,
it's the wrong test for these
data set, it's very silly.
Or your whole product
is wrong, we've
done that before, you
don't need to repeat it.
Do it this way.
Some fields are experimenting
with these options,
and I'm not saying that
all fields should adopt
open live streaming, but I think
moving more from level zero
to level one, two, three,
four, five may be beneficial.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the
point of registration,
then, that you get the criticism
earlier and save people time?
DR. IOANNIDIS: The question
is whether by registering
you get the criticism earlier.
Part of the benefit is that.
But I think that there's
also more transparency.
So in a way,
registration would help
cure some of the
publication bias problem.
Because people would
know that even though I
see one study that is published,
there's 30 studies out there.
Where is the other 29?
I need to go and
find their results
before I make some conclusions
and start policy actions based
on the one that is published.
So I think that there could be
many benefits at many layers.
And obviously we
have a good sense
of what the research
agenda looks like.
Funders or other
scientists may decide
that here we have
50 studies already.
Why do we need yet another one?
So it could be a multiple
level of benefits.
This is an empirical
evaluation looking
at how common data sharing is
in different scientific journals
in the articles that
they've published.
We looked at the 50
highest impact factor
journals across
science, and we tried
to see if they have
policies in place
for sharing of materials,
of protocols, of raw data,
and also whether it may be a
prerequisite for publication.
And if you see green color,
that's very good news.
It means that these journals
do have policies in place
for different aspects
of the sharing process.
But the last column,
which is very tiny
font-- You have to trust me,
but there's lots of zeros.
And these zeroes are the
number of papers out of 10
that we screened in each one
of these journals that actually
adhered to these policies.
So there's lots of sensitization
about these issues,
but when it comes
to real life, it's
very difficult to
find the raw data.
And even if you want
to waste your time
to repeat the analysis,
it's not really doable.
So if you want to waste your
time, what would you get?
A few years ago, I
gathered a number
of colleagues who were very
interested in microarray
analysis around the
world, and we got in touch
with Myles Axton, the
editor of "Nature Genetics."
And we said, your general
has been visionary.
This is true.
You have a policy
in place that data
should be shared in public as
a prerequisite for publication
for microarray studies.
So let's try to see whether
we can repeat the analysis
and specific tables or
figures from microarray papers
published in "Nature Genetics."
Impact factor of 40,
one of the best journals
across any scientific field.
And this is what we did.
Out of 18 papers that we
tried to repeat the analysis,
we could repeat the
analysis only for two.
And for the others,
we could reproduce
with some
discrepancies, we could
reproduce from process data
with some discrepancies,
could reproduce partially
and then the majority we
could not reproduce at all.
And the reasons for that?
The data basis were not
available, actually,
even though they
were supposed to be.
Software were not
available, were homemade
and had disappeared.
The methods were unclear.
So none of the
experts in the team
could understand
what was happening.
Or people could understand
what was happening,
but we got a very
different result.
So this is one of the highest
impact factor journals, one
of the most
transparent journals,
research by the very best teams.
And repeatability
is two out of 18.
A little bit over 10%.
The other question is who's
going to do the replication?
Will it be the
same investigators?
Would it be different
investigators
of the same school?
Would it be different
investigators
of competing theories
or hypotheses?
Combinations of the above?
Would it be open
to the wide public?
Anyone?
Especially we have
these raw data
sets available in public view?
I think the results and
the replication profile
could be different depending
on who is replicating.
And all of these ideas are
currently really being debated.
It's a very hot debate about
what type of reproducibility
we need.
And there's lots of
an initiatives that
are appearing around the
world to try to do that.
So, for example, Brian Nosek
has launched the Center
for Open Science,
focusing mostly
on psychological
and social sciences
repeatability and
reproducibility.
The Reproducibility
Initiative has
started replicating the
most highly cited research
in cell biology.
And it has an open initiative
also for other studies
to be repeated by
independent labs.
As [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned, we recently
launched with Steve Goodman
METRICS, the Meta-Research
Innovation Center
at Stanford, which
we aim to try to coalesce
all of these efforts
around the world on
different aspects
of reproducible research
and research and research.
So anyone who might
be interested to join
in that effort, please
send me an email
or find a way to reach me.
If I don't respond immediately,
please, I apologize.
But sometimes I get overwhelmed.
But we're very excited about
probing different possibilities
about how to promote
reproducible research.
To do that, maybe we
need to change the reward
systems and the
incentive systems.
If, for example, funding
agencies, all they want
is significant
results and claims
for major discoveries,
this what they will get.
Significant results and
claims for discoveries.
If we realign the incentives
both for funding agencies
and for institutions and
for research institutes
and for companies to get
translatable results, results
that you can make sense of, that
you can apply, that you can get
something out for the real
world, reproducible results,
high-quality results, this
would be a very different story.
And one note of caveat.
I don't want us to
reach the other end
of the spectrum,
the other extreme.
Just having too much
wasted replication.
Here's one example.
This is an interesting topic.
This is status for prevention
of atrial fibrillation
after cardiac surgery.
Should one use statons
in that setting?
Good question.
I would like to know the answer.
There are randomized
trials about that.
There's also
meta-analyses about that.
How many meta-analyses
are out there?
There's 11 meta-analyses
when we published that paper.
I think there's 14 now.
Why do we need 14 efforts
to perform meta-analysis
on these data sets?
Within three years, practically.
They all get the same result.
The first one was inconclusive.
But after that they all
got the same result.
So some broader picture of what
is the research agenda looking
like may be helpful to
avoid wasting resources
for performing the fifteenth
meta-analysis on the very
same topic and allocating
resources more wisely.
And this is another caveat.
We have to take into
account a changing world.
This is another field that
we recently looked at.
This is genetic meta-analysis.
And the different bars here
represent genetic meta-analyses
from different countries.
The blue bar is not the US.
The blue bar is China.
So in that field China went
from 1% less than 10 years ago
to about 60, 70% of the
entire global production
in English-language, high
impact factor journals.
Or good impact factor journals.
That's interesting.
I do believe that
China is really
the new giant in
science, and I see
that in many different fields.
We took a closer look to
see what's happening here.
So we looked at these papers.
In terms of reporting,
they look great.
They look wonderful.
The tables are very meticulous,
very well structured.
The details about the
methods, they're very nice.
Wonderful.
But almost all of
them are wrong.
Why's that?
Because they depend
on collecting
fragments of
published information
on specific genetic
associations.
So pretty much the
same literature
that I showed you in one
of the earlier slides?
These are meta-analyses
compiling the small pieces
of information
that are published.
They cannot take into account
the very large initiatives that
have data sets that are
50 or 100 times larger
and conclusively fine null
results for these associations.
Just because they're
not available.
It's not their fault.
But they just gather what they
can see under the lamppost.
And what they can see
under the lamppost
is very limited, fragmented,
and potentially highly biased.
So to conclude, I
think that there's
a very large number of
conscious, unconscious,
and subconscious biases that
can operate in the research
process.
This is likely to be
just human nature,
and we should take
that for granted.
We should just try to see
how we can work through that.
Replication,
reproducibility practices
vary a lot across
different research fields.
And I think that the
adoption of these practices
can be key to the success
rates, efficiency, credibility,
and legacy of each field.
Fields that are noncredible
can become highly credible,
others that are credible
can lose credibility,
depending on what
practices they adopt.
And I think that it's
a huge research area
to understand which are
really the best practices
to improve our
credibility rates.
I just want to thank
a few of my colleagues
that have been involved in
some of the empirical studies
that I showed you today.
Since I'm famous because most of
my published research findings
are wrong, they should
not be blamed for that.
I think that the
part that was wrong
is mine, the part that
was correct is theirs.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Back to where you have
all those studies where they
continue to produce
inconclusive results,
that would suggest to me
that there's somebody out
there that wants
to find a result.
And they keep trying
to find that result.
Is that how you see it?
DR. IOANNIDIS: Absolutely.
I think that there is a
lot of confirmation bias.
If people have
developed a theory
or they have a field
that is expecting
to find some associations or
some effects or some results
and they don't see
that, they will just
keep analyzing the data or keep
accruing other research efforts
until they get that
result that they want.
I think this is very risky.
Because it creates bubbles
of scientific disciplines.
I think that many
scientific disciplines
are just bubbles like the candid
gene association bubble that
burst when we had better
studies, larger studies,
with more careful
characterization of both
the genome and
better sample sizes.
How common these bubbles are?
I think it's open for debate.
I think most scientists
would be defensive
that their own field
is not a bubble.
But I suspect that there's
many bubbles out there.
AUDIENCE: While
there's certainly
a bias towards publishing
positive results,
how can we account for the
fact that there's probably also
a bias for testing
relationships for which there's
a plausible mechanism
in the first place?
So we're not just testing random
predictors on our outcome,
but rather things that we
could believe plausibly
or scientifically that would
influence that outcome?
DR. IOANNIDIS: I
think that there
is room for incorporating
plausibility,
biological plausibility,
and other lines of evidence
in designing studies.
I'm not saying that
everything should be agnostic.
And in many cases, we have
tons of previous evidence
that we need to
take into account.
So for example, if
I were to design
a large-scale randomized
trial to test a new treatment,
probably I will not take
any treatment to be tested.
I will take one that has gone
through pre-clinical research,
early clinical research, early
phase studies, phase one, two,
and it shows promising
results all along.
So by the time I
get there, I have
incorporated all that
previous evidence
and decided that
this is a good study
to do to have the conclusive
result of whether it
does really work.
However, in most circumstances,
in my experience,
and in a number of empirical
studies that we have done,
biological plausibility
is inflated.
It's overinterpreted.
People used biological
plausibility
in ways that suit their needs.
And much of the
time it is post hoc.
They find the result.
And then they draw
the circle around it.
And it's interesting.
Any result can be explained
away as being plausible.
I cannot think of any result
that someone could not summon
biological plausibility.
So how do you solve that?
I think you need registration.
You need to have registration
of a protocol that says,
specifically, this
is my hypothesis,
and this is what I base it on.
This is the plausibility
argument, or arguments,
that I have, and let's
see what happens.
And then it's a good choice.
And if it's a nice
result, that's great.
Whatever the result
is, then it's valuable.
AUDIENCE: Professor,
based on your research,
would you say that
science currently
is undergoing a crisis episode?
Given the number of papers
that are simply wrong?
DR. IOANNIDIS: Is science
undergoing a crisis.
AUDIENCE: And if so, how urgent
would you say it is to fix it?
DR. IOANNIDIS: It depends
on how you define crisis.
If crisis is synonymous with
we have been infiltrated
by millions of
fraudulent people, no.
If crisis is that our efficiency
is very low, I would say yes.
I think that the efficiency of
many practices of conducting
research currently is very low.
We have a lot of waste.
If you see that as a
machine, the machine
could operate far
more efficiently.
And the question is what
are the best interventions
to improve that efficiency?
In a series of papers
in "The Lancet"
along with several
colleagues earlier this year,
we estimated that the waste
in biomedical research
is about 85%.
So is that a crisis?
I would argue it's a
very high percentage.
Some might argue that,
well, that's not bad,
15%, I mean, it could be 1%.
I think I'm an optimist.
I believe that 15% could
become 40% and or 60%.
It's unlikely it
will become 100%.
Science is very difficult,
and even under the very best
intentions we will
keep making lots
of errors and lots of
suboptimal choices.
But I think we can get that
15% to a much higher range.
And I think that this is true
for many other scientific
domains even beyond biomedicine.
AUDIENCE: Have you are
anyone else looked into
at what point in the research
process results become wrong?
So do studies typically
have poor designs?
Or do the samples
get mixed up, or are
there bugs in the software?
Or maybe the data's correct
and wrongly interpreted.
Do you have any sense of that?
DR. IOANNIDIS: So
what is the stage
that most studies get it wrong.
It's a continuum.
There's multiple
phases, and each phase
has its waste contribution.
And there's waste
contribution even
from selecting the study
to perform or the question.
There's lots of
studies that just
have no rationale
that should be done.
If someone says, I'm going
to do another meta-analysis
on statons for prevention
of atrial fibrillation,
I will say, well,
we have 14 already.
Why do we need a fifteenth?
But I'm sure that
there will be one.
Probably in the next few months.
There's then a lot of
waste in the design.
There's lots of waste in
the conduct of the study.
the analysis of the data.
There's lots of waste in
the reporting of the data.
the post-publication or
post-publication interpretation
and use and implementation
of the database or
whatever they mean.
It's not just one point.
AUDIENCE: Has it
been quantified?
Can you say that a
quarter of papers
are wrong because
of a software bug?
DR. IOANNIDIS: It
has been qualified
for specific subsets
of scientific fields.
I think it would be misleading
to say that all fields are
suffering more from one
of these five steps.
Depending on the field,
you may have more waste
in an early phase
or a late phase.
AUDIENCE: What
does this research
lead you to think about
the role of journals?
Certainly they've
come under criticism
for the fees they charge
people to access them
and things like that.
Do you see journals as
driving change here,
or is this something
where there are
things in addition to
instead of journals
that are getting the registered
studies or other information
out there?
DR. IOANNIDIS: Journals can be
a very influential stakeholder
in the whole process.
Because they control much of
their reward and incentive
system.
So this means that they
can make thing far worse,
or they can make
things far better.
One example where they
make things far worse
is where you have
generals that are
willing to accept
practically anything,
hardly with any peer review.
There was that hoax
that was published
in "Science" several months ago.
300 journals were
sent a paper that
was a fake paper with all the
errors that you could imagine,
and half of them accepted it.
And another 20% were
still considering it.
They can do things much better.
So, for example, registration
of clinical trials
would not have been
successful unless all
the major clinical journals
had agreed that we're not
going to publish a clinical
trial unless it is registered.
People have been talking
about registration for ages.
I remember the 1990s.
BMJ had come up with a nice
idea about a trial amnesty,
saying, if you haven't
published your results,
we will forgive you.
Come out and tell
us what you found.
Nobody came out to
tell what they found.
But if "BMJ" and "JAMA" and
"Lancet" and "New England
Journal of Medicine" and all the
major specialty journals said,
we're not going to publish your
work unless it's registered,
then it'd happen.
It creates new challenges.
Now that we have
registered studies,
we see that, well,
there's other caveats.
So you could still
register a study,
but the protocol may
not be very transparent.
There's still lots of leeway
for vibration of effects
and for exploration
of the analysis
that you want to present.
So now we need to work on that.
How do you get
journals to buy in
that you don't need to
just register a study
and say, oh, yeah,
I'm doing a study,
but really be precise
about what is being done
and how it's going to be done?
So journals are a
major stakeholder.
They could really affect
the whole system enormously.
AUDIENCE: So with
many hypothesis tests
it's very simple and well
understood how the power and p
values change as a
function of sample size.
So I was wondering if there
are any inferences you
have from distributions of
sample sizes and p values.
Is there a big
cluster of p values
just below 0.05 when you
look across these studies,
for example?
DR. IOANNIDIS: There are
several studies, empirically,
that have looked at
different fields.
And they find that there is a
concentration of p values very
close to the 0.05 magic number.
Most of that work has been done
in the psychological sciences,
and there's a big hump
just next to the 0.05.
In my experience, when we've
looked at different data sets
in other fields of epidemiology,
we see a hump next to 0.05.
Not necessarily less than 0.05.
It could be less but
also slightly higher.
And these are papers that
have what we call "spin."
So people get a p
value of 0.07, but they
say, oh, we found
an association.
0.07, it's the same as 0.05.
But 0.07 could be
0.08, 0.10, 0.12.
There are attractors in
the p value distribution.
And this is highly visible,
especially in fields
that have a very long
tradition of working
with specific thresholds
that claim who is the winner.
Even in fields that have
rigorous statistical
thresholds.
For example, genome-wide
association studies.
We have accepted that
instead of a p value of 0.05,
we need a p value of 5
times 10 to the minus 8.
You still see a hump very
close to the 5 times 10
to the minus 8.
But at least you hope that,
and empirically shows,
that most of these
values that are
very close to that
threshold are replicable.
So in contrast to those that
are just in this 0.05 threshold.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
following up on that,
do you think we make
the problem worse
by focusing on the
wrong statistics?
Maybe we shouldn't focus
on p values at all,
but rather have confidence
intervals over effect size.
DR. IOANNIDIS: Possibly.
For a long time, I
have argued, of course,
in favor of effect sizes and
uncertainty surrounding them.
I have also suggested that
many other colleagues have
done the same, that
it would be better
to use Bayesian approaches in
presenting and interpreting
results.
However, I want to be honest.
I don't think that changing
the inferential rules
from a frequentist
approach, let's say,
to a fully Bayesian
approach will necessarily
cure these problems.
For example, if you
embed into people's minds
that a base factor of 1,000
is what they should be looking
for, people will just try to
get a base factor of 1,000.
They were trying to
get a p value of 0.05,
now they will try to get
a base factor of 1,000.
The one difference is
the base factor of 1,000
would be something that would
be more directly interpretable.
And it would be
easier to understand
what it means for
other purposes rather
than for the bias of
twisting the analysis
to get a result
passing the threshold.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
All right, that's
all the time we
have for questions,
but I think Dr. Ioannidis will
be around for a little bit
to answer questions.
So let's give him a
big round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]